I came to United States in 1985 and
coming from Poland at that time Carnegie
Mellon was the very special place you
can do things which were not possible
before so this was beginning of computer
science robotics but also Carnegie
Mellon was a very strong in polymer
science so Paul flurry Nobel laureate
was a director of Mellon Institute
before going to Stanford and there was a
many polymer scientists here in
chemistry department so this was very
easy choice for me
one side it is very interdisciplinary
institution but it's very easy to
collaborate and I think the essence of
the science in 21st century is really
bridging between different areas
different disciplines so not on the
chemistry but chemistry and biology
chemistry and computer science chemistry
and robotics and I think chemistry is
really a very central science chemistry
enables any progress made not only in
chemical sciences but also in biology in
medicine in nanotechnology in material
science in robotics electronics computer
science and others but polymer chemistry
is even more because polymer chemistry
can be really seen in some sense that
you can make macromolecules which can be
really so large and so special but you
can see individual molecules and they
can be used for special actions they can
respond to external stimuli to
temperature to pH to many others so
polymers are probably in that case my
excitement because there are also much
larger molecules and much more powerful
in the sense of a function but polymer
chemistry is a lil bit more than just
chemistry because it deals with the
large molecules with macromolecules and
Vees macromolecules can have a very
different properties than an average
chemicals they are sometimes behaving
like elastic materials you can from
glasses you can from gels of the
precisely control structures you can you
them for delivery of drugs in a very
specific way you can use them for
improving surface properties of various
materials so this is really challenge
but also opportunity atom transfer
radical polymerization of a TRP for
short is a new method of making polymers
and it was discovered approximately
twenty years ago it is one of the
methods of radical polymerization
although conventional radical
polymerization known for hundred years
and responsible for making nearly half
of all polymers in the world in the
amount of hundred billion kilograms per
year or one kilogram per month per
person
everybody in u.s. or everywhere in the
world
so it's a huge amount of polymers but
still they are you would defined they
are not really controlled the way we
would like to have so the reason for
that is that the radical polymerization
proceeds with free radicals and free
radicals whether in chemistry or in
politics I extremely difficult to be
controlled they killing one another via
committing suicide after one second time
so one second time is too short to make
a polymer chain in a precise way make a
block of polymer or something else so
the approach which we taken in 20 years
ago is really based on putting these
radicals to sleep to a dormant state for
a certain period of time let's say one
minute and in that case we can have
possibility of extending is one second
life of propagating chain to thousand
minutes sometimes even longer this
allows us to make totally different
polymers polymers which will have a
shape of a star or calm ring or
sometimes making block copolymers or
gradient copolymers and functional
polymers something which was not
possible before and now a TRP is used
commercially in many countries to
produce various advanced materials
sometimes even intelligent smart
materials
think Pittsburgh is something in which
both myself and my wife we are laughs
with visit and it's a very special city
in many aspects I think it's also
possibility of having very good students
working hard and I think the motive of
the Motor Company from Andrew Carnegie
that his heart was in his work I think
applies very much to everybody here